okay here are the questions from the
internet I wanted to get to this in the
show I'm glad somebody yesterday what do
you think the Norwegian government's
reaction will be after the terror attack
yeah there was a terrible attack today
in Oslo and I want to read I had this
quote from the Prime Minister he said
our answer is more democracy more
openness to show that we will not be
stopped by this kind of violence I don't
think that's anything an American
politician would ever say after an
attack we would only go to the more
security more cancelling the Bill of
Rights because we're pan occurs no but
you know you're right that I mean one of
the problems with America over the past
decade has been that we've constantly
been running from panic to panic it was
we had to pass the Patriot Act within
you know a couple days of 9/11 we had to
pass tarp over the course of a weekend
otherwise you know the ATM machines
wouldn't work we had to get into Libya
before there was a genocide you know
this is no way to run a government and
we have to pass a bill that's gonna bind
us for the next decade in a couple of
weeks I mean this this is just not the
way adults are supposed to act well
except for that last one what we
actually do but no we don't yes we know
we need to we need to make sure that we
don't miss a debt payment which we have
enough money to pay and then we need to
figure it out and we're in a slow-motion
default on all right but I think about
the violence about the attack of it
that's something in America we do have a
really muscular insular response to that
you know because I think something in
our in our DNA says that we're going to
live forever
I think people who've lived in other
countries that are older than ours that
they know they're going to die and they
live with the idea of death and we don't
and I think when that happens to us we
we we we flip right around and in a way
that's very you know protective in the
show and really hurt ourselves yes
I mean the more is in Afghanistan Iraq
and fighting in the terrorism in
Pakistan they say is gonna cost us four
trillion dollars well there's your does
your deficit reduction that what's that
we're all fighting about if we hadn't
fought those wars people who can afford
to pay more simply pay nothing is
stopping you the Treasury Department has
a has a website where you can I can do
that wait can I just say though the the
intervention in Afghanistan to go after
bin Laden and they add they said to the
Taliban
turn them over you're harboring and they
the Taliban didn't play ball so we went
into Afghanistan I think that made sense
the real problem with that is that we
hung out there with absolutely no idea
of what we're doing and we're still
there right and this is also something
that Obama who was an act you know he
got elected partly because people are
like oh he's not going to be a complete
dick on wars like Bush was and he
tripled the number of troops in
Afghanistan and now next year he'll
reduce it down to where they were when
he took office and yeah and over ten
years so it raised it more it's also on
the chopping block it's it's another
it's it should be shouldn't even be open
we should take care of those veterans
and we should pay them on August 3rd
Kali asked would you like to see a
Democrat challenge Obama in 2012 that's
not possible but that's not the question
would you like to see it
that's not bill I'm alright I'm on the
I'm on the committee it's not possible
Obama some of the things that he's
proposing to do to try to get us back
down the fiscal path of growth it's not
possible
I don't believe there's a democratic
America today well you can run bill but
you'll get you ass whipped I don't vote
for president why you know you pay taxes
I certainly do okay because I'm a coward
I don't even take all of my deductions
because I'm afraid that they're gonna
come after me I personally would like to
see a Democrat in the White House I
can't only think that he was the
situation after election night in
November 2008 what part of the Obama
team who were pretty damn smart to get
elected what part of them didn't save
themselves gee I wonder if the
Republicans would just give us a pass
for the next four years
what part of them did not envision the
vitriolic attack that started on that
day on election day determined to turn
him into Jimmy Carter what part of it
didn't say on January 20th okay this is
what's gonna happen it's gonna take not
four years we got into this ditch over
eight years it's gonna take us eight
years stick with it Jimmy Carter
I wish you want about Jimmy Carter but
Jimmy Carter was a Democratic president
who had Democratic policies this is not
a president let's be honest who really
has democratic policies I mean what
we're good on civil liberties he's not
good on war I mean that yeah I keep his
I could on drug legalization who refuses
to actually endorse gay marriage I mean
who needs him
well we do need him and he's certainly
better than the alternative and I'd say
you know what he is dealing with is
unprecedented
never has a pray mean let's be honest
that is so tiring everybody kidding so
if there was a deal like there was there
is on the table now with Bob Dole and
Howard Baker and those old Republicans
alan simpson they would have signed that
from the grave tonight assignment rights
three point five trillion okay I gotta
go thank you folks
[Applause]
[Music]